[Musik]
ich kandidiere offiziell für das amt des
us präsidenten
die medien waren geschlossen gegen nicht
da hat er sich mit hilfe von twitter
seinen weg geebnet downloads chance sagt
uns was er denn getan
da weiß man was man hat und das bedeutet
bei einer führungsperson
[Musik]
ich spreche aus was wir brauchen ist ein
einreiseverbot
auch wenn man ein öffentliches amt
bekleidet darf man sich noch verteidigen
robert de niro ein individuum mit sehr
niedrigen iq hat in den filmen von
echten boxern soviel schläge gegen den
kopf abgetrennt
das ist klasse er ist definitiv der
lustigste präsidentin wer je hat so darf
man als führer der freien welt nicht
daher reden
ich glaube hat kein frühstadium von den
menschen sondern von faschismus anthonys
karachi ist ein völlig labiler spinne
wall street eine der am meisten
überschätzten schauspieler
in meinen augen hat er eine neue form
der kommunikation erfolgt die letzte
echte präsidiale erfindung sachen
kommunikation waren wohl die
kamingespräche von außen